Entonces tengo un rectángulo aquí, y mi objetivo
es dividir este rectángulo en cuadrados iguales
más pequeños, y la forma en que voy a hacer eso es
dividiendo primero este rectángulo en dos filas -y
debería decir 2 filas iguales-, y luego voy a
dividir este rectángulo en 5 columnas iguales.
Ahora, sé que algunos de ustedes se preguntan
¿qué es una fila y qué es una columna? Bueno,
una fila -al menos mi cerebro así la imagina- es
una parte del rectángulo que va de izquierda a
derecha. Una forma de pensarlo es: si tuviera
un montón de manzanas aquí y quisiera dividir
esas manzanas en filas, diría que esta es la
primera fila, esta es una segunda fila y que
esta es una tercera fila. Si tuviera que pensar
en términos de columnas, tiendo a pensar que
las columnas van de arriba hacia abajo, entonces
esta sería una columna, esta sería otra columna,
esta sería una tercera columna y esta sería una
cuarta columna. Entonces, ahora que entendemos qué
son las filas y las columnas, pausa este video y
piensa cómo dividir este rectángulo en dos filas.
Bueno, la forma en que lo abordaría sería primero
dibujar una recta que va de izquierda a derecha;
y ahí lo tienes: ahora tengo el rectángulo
dividido en una fila y otra fila. Ahora pausa
el video y trata de dibujar esto si tienes un
lápiz y papel contigo, o simplemente podrías
pensar en lo que deberías hacer. ¿Cómo dividimos
ahora este rectángulo en 5 columnas? Bueno,
lo que podemos hacer es dibujar varias rectas
de arriba abajo, entonces esta es una columna,
esta es una segunda columna, esta es una tercera
columna, esta es una cuarta columna y una quinta
columna. Entonces ahí lo tienes, tengo 2 filas
-una fila, dos filas- y tengo 5 columnas -una,
dos, tres, cuatro y cinco-. Ahora, lo interesante
es que cuando divido el rectángulo de esta manera
en 2 filas y 5 columnas, ¿cuántos cuadrados de
igual tamaño hay? Bueno, he creado 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 cuadrados iguales, y eso tiene
sentido porque cada fila tiene 5: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5;
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, y 5 + 5 = 10. Otra forma de pensar
en esto es que cada columna tiene 2 cuadrados:
1-2, 1-2, 1-2, 1-2, 1-2, y 2 + 2 son 4 + 2
son 6 + 2 son 8 + 2 son 10. Entonces esto
es lo que resulta de dividir el rectángulo en 2
filas y 5 columnas, lo divide en 10 secciones.